So Donald Trump actually granted a post-election
interview now that the Supreme Court rejected
hearing another bogus lawsuit about so-called
voter fraud.
This wasn't a real interview in the sense
that Trump would be asked actual questions
and put in a position to defend his claims
with facts.
It wasn't an interview in that sense.
It was actually the opposite.
It was an interview where Donald Trump was
given the repeated opportunity to make claims
not based in reality without being challenged
on anything.
And the interviewer is Brian Kilmeade from
Fox News.
Despite claims that Fox News has gone liberal
now by Newsmax and on, Brian Kilmeade was
there to ensure that no one for a second could
think Fox News remains anything but a right
wing propaganda channel.
And to be clear, there are countries where
if you do an interview like this, while claiming
to be a reporter or journalist, you would
be publicly ostracized and you might even
have to resign from your job because you would
be so ashamed, publicly shamed for doing an
interview like this in the United States at
Fox News.
I guess you sort of get an attaboy for doing
an interview like this.
In fact, Brian Kilmeade helped Trump spread
the lies in this first clip.
Brian Kilmeade echoes the lie that Donald
Trump has previously told, which is when Barack
Obama left office and Trump took over, the
military had no ammunition, they had no bullets.
The cupboards were bare, which could not be
more of a brazen lie.
Take a look.
I think you accomplished you took over a military
that was cut by twenty five percent.
Yeah.
That only had three brigades ready to fight
and was out of bullets.
What have you done in the four years since
you to change that entirely rebuilt military
like never before.
New missiles and rockets and tanks and ships
and planes.
And we have the F-35 is coming in by the hundreds.
As you know, when I took over, we had a depleted
military.
We had no ammunition.
I'll never forget a very overrated general
coming to see me and saying, sir, we have
no ammunition.
I'm sorry.
This is my first two days in office.
And I say no president should ever have to
hear that and no president should ever be
spied on either.
You know, so we we said a lot of records,
but we have a totally rebuilt and our nuclear
is now tippy top.
And just hope to God you never have to use
it today.
The idea that our military was out of bullets
is so absurd that it's hilarious if you understand
the stranglehold that the military industrial
complex has over our country and government
and economy, including both Democrats and
Republicans.
It's a laughable claim.
Trump, by the way, also slipping in the lie
that Obama spied on his campaign, which at
this point is a comedy.
You know, it's it's a comedy meme outside
of Trump World.
Trump then went on to revive another completely
bonkers notion that he previously tweeted
about, which is that, listen, if you need
proof that I really won this thing election
night, the bookies had me winning the election.
And so clearly, Joe Biden must have stolen
it.
This actually has to be seen to be believed,
but in a sense, it's logical, casino guy Trump
says.
Look at the bookies for proof that this was
stolen, the election was over at 10 o'clock
in the evening, I had one it was 97, 98 percent
of all of the bookies all over the world were
saying the election's over.
They wouldn't even take bets on it.
And then all of a sudden around 11 o'clock,
ballots start getting dropped.
You ever see the graph where you go like this
and then it goes up to this guy.
Tens of thousands of ballots were being illegally
dropped.
The machines are the worst dominion, dominion.
Nobody even knows who owns it.
These machines are controlling our country.
So it was a rigged election.
It was a it was really a sham and a shame
when you at least now he's calling them massive
ballot drops rather than massive dumps.
But what he's saying is not any more logical.
He lost the election, plain and simple.
Now, this next clip is amazing because it's
the height of projection.
Trump says he's worried.
He's worried.
Guys, Trump is worried that having an illegitimate
president would be bad for the country.
Now, when Trump says an illegitimate president,
he means Joe Biden.
But, of course, Joe Biden won.
So it's Trump who would be the illegitimate
president if he somehow figured out a way
to stay in power.
When you when you look at this fight, though,
you have seventy seven percent of Trump supporters
who believe you won the election, according
to a Fox playbook.
I've heard actually much higher numbers is
there's a rally right now in Washington for
that.
Do you worry about the country being divided
as if it goes to inauguration and they still
feel that way and you still feel that way?
No, I worry about the country having an illegitimate
president.
That's what I worry about, a president that
lost and lost badly.
This wasn't like a close election.
You look at Georgia.
We won Georgia big.
We won Pennsylvania big.
We won Wisconsin big.
We won it big.
But you're gonna win all of these states.
Do you think your legal team has proven that?
Well, we don't we never get a chance to prove
it because a judge will say, well, I'm sorry,
you don't have standing.
Like, how about me, Texas and all of these
states, 18 or 19 altogether, they come and
think how nice that is, where they actually
come in and they say, we want to support you,
sir, because you're important to this country.
We want to support you.
They go in and they say the states don't have
standing.
And I don't have I'm president of the United
States.
I just got seventy five million votes, the
biggest number of votes in the history of
our country ever gotten by a sitting president.
By the way, let's not forget the absolute
travesty of Brian Kilmeade setting up these
softball questions for Trump, a true journalistic
perversion.
He should be ashamed of himself.
But Trump continues to just be unable to be
parodied because what he says is so ridiculous,
he's worried we might have an illegitimate
president.
Yeah, I am, too.
We just disagree about who that would be.
I think the guy who won would be the legitimate
president.
Trump thinks the guy who won would be illegitimate
in that it's Joe Biden in his mind.
Now, this next one is interesting.
Brian Kilmeade actually asks Trump who rigged
the election.
Now, if we actually get that, that's like
question one point.
If you first ask, what do you think of the
results?
And Trump says they were rigged against me,
the first logical journalistic follow up is
who rigged it and how.
And it starts to get a little more interesting.
I didn't lose the election was rigged by who?
By the Democrats and actually interesting
by the Democrats, but by local Democrats,
meaning state Democrats.
They outsmarted state Republicans.
You know what I do?
I do two things.
I run a country and we cut taxes and we did
all of the things, regulations, space for
us.
So that's Trump continuing to throw the state
Republicans under the bus.
Now, of course, a real journalist, if Brian
Kilmeade were one, would have had a dozen
follow up questions based on this.
He didn't.
But it's interesting to see Trump throw state
Republicans under the bus because that's code
for people like Georgia Governor Brian Kemp,
who was unwilling to do illegal maneuvering
to try to steal this election for Donald Trump.
And that's very interesting because it's not
praise of Brian Kemp in any real way.
Brian, remember, Brian Kemp is a disgusting
and depraved guy.
But the point is, when even Brian Kemp is
unwilling to help a Republican, it's because
what Trump is asking for is that absurd.
And by the way, Brian Kemp, I'm guessing,
probably realizes no matter what he does,
even if he were able to overturn Georgia,
Joe Biden still win.
So why would he do it?
This last one is genius.
Trump says that they I guess, meaning Biden,
Democrats, his opponents, they are winning
on technicalities like the Supreme Court saying
Texas doesn't have standing to bring the lawsuit,
which we're going to talk about in a moment.
No judge has had the courage, including the
Supreme Court.
I am so disappointed in them.
No judge, including the Supreme Court of the
United States, has had the courage to allow
it to be heard.
The Supreme Court.
All they did is say we don't have standing.
So they're saying essentially that the president
of the United States and Texas and these other
states, great state.
They don't have standing.
They didn't go into the evidence, if you would
look at the evidence.
Thousands of pages of evidence.
We have over a thousand affidavits from people.
So Trump again mentions affidavits which are
neither here nor there.
And when we looked at the affidavits, they
actually read like comedy scripts.
But the issue of standing is an important
one.
The Supreme Court did decide, did say Texas
does not have standing to challenge the results
in these four states.
Now, in law, standing means you can demonstrate
to the court that you're connected to the
harm from the action that is being challenged
from the law that is being challenged and
that supports you being in the case.
So if I want to bring a lawsuit, I have to
have some kind of standing, some connection
to I'm being affected in some way or whatever
the case may be for Texas to have standing
and suing over the results in Georgia, Pennsylvania,
whatever you would have to say.
And this is, I think, roughly the argument
they made.
Well, if the Georgia and Wisconsin and Pennsylvania,
if those elections were fraudulent, it essentially
devalues the election we held in Texas.
It makes our election not matter.
It disenfranchizes Texas.
If other elections are fraudulent, as they
claim, it's very, very loose.
And Supreme Court said no.
So it's not a technicality.
It's it's sort of a fundamental issue when
it comes to one's ability to bring complaints
to courts.
And then.
Absolutely, last clip and then we're going
to move on.
Donald Trump was asked, given that the Supreme
Court did this, is it all over?
And Trump says, no, we're going to keep going.
Found out late last night that the Supreme
Court would not hear the Texas case and did
not have standing, according to them.
Eisuke, Judge, by judging by your tweets,
are very, very disappointed in that.
Is it over?
No, it's not over.
We keep going and we're going to continue
to go forward.
We have numerous local cases where, you know,
and some of the states have got now, what
are the next stages of keeping going?
I don't know.
So an absolutely disgusting interview.
Another one in the books for Donald Trump.
There are fewer remaining sort of be pleased
by that, at least with Trump as president
later today.
We'll talk about the electoral vote certification
that's happening.
And big announcement, January 1st.
Twenty twenty one.
OK, first day of the new year.
We are going to be doing a January one twenty,
twenty one membership special, the likes of
which this country has never seen.
Now, because these these discounts that we
do are so huge, they may be illegal under
a Biden administration.
So before Biden comes in and says no more
discounts that are this big, we are doing
a January one single day membership drive.
I would really encourage you to participate
in this, to be notified.
Just get on our newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
Very, very easy.
Get on our newsletter.
January one, you'll get an email saying, here's
how you sign up.
An amazing, amazing day.
It's going to be.
And last absolutely last thing.
Follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
where you have the ability to see even more
clips
of
the show,